uh this is really funny as many of you
know or maybe you don't and i'll tell
you
joe biden is sort of doing pretty okay
as president
there's no perfect president ever
president every president does lots of
things that
people don't agree with that i don't
agree with okay but
in this hyper-polarized enviro
environment that we have in the united
states
joe biden's approval is quite healthy
it's much higher than donald trump's
ever was
and joe biden already in these first few
months of his presidency has some
important major achievements including
the covet relief bill
including an incredibly successful
vaccine rollout
and some other things with much more
planned fox news
and other right-wing media are
completely out of ideas about what to
cover
they tried fake scandals they tried
ginning up a crisis at the border which
sort of worked actually
they tried attacking the relationship
between joe and jill biden as fake and
stage managed for public perception
and none of it is really sticking i mean
the border thing is sticking a little
bit
but a lot of this stuff is just not
sticking and
look at the pathetic things that they
tried last night alone
here is tucker carlson claiming that joe
biden's
secretary of defense lloyd austin said
that the single greatest risk
our soldiers face is having to serve
alongside
trump supporters but when you watch the
clip of lloyd austin that he plays
lloyd austin doesn't actually say that
it is a fake
scandal take a look existential
if you've got a cliche he will read it
on television lloyd austin of course
lloyd austin is a former defense
contractor not surprisingly he's a
full-time audio log as well
having lloyd austin at the pentagon is
like handing control of the entire u.s
military to the editorial page of the
new york times
here is lloyd austin explaining that the
single scariest risk
our soldiers face is the possibility
they might have to serve
alongside americans who didn't vote for
joe biden
and if confirmed i will fight hard to
stamp out sexual assault
and to rid our ranks of racist and
extremists
the job of the department of defense is
to keep america safe from our enemies
but we can't do that if some of those
enemies lie within our own ranks
he's a joke and a mediocrity and of
course he was confirmed
by the senate as if he was impressive
but he's not so understand that
tucker says lloyd austin claimed
the biggest risk to our troops is
serving alongside people who didn't vote
for joe biden
he plays a clip and in the clip lloyd
austin says we've got to get
sexual assault out of the military we've
got to get racists out of the military
and we've got to get extremists out of
the military now maybe tucker carlson
knows that the racists and the
extremists and the sexual assaulters are
trump supporters
i don't know i'm not saying that but uh
linguistically
i can't see any other connection between
what tucker carlson
said is in that clip and what lloyd
austin actually says
then tucker carlson uses the latest bill
gates jeffrey epstein revelations to
just
wide openly pander to the q anon people
take a look at this
so just days after bill gates told us on
twitter
that he was getting a divorce there is
new information about his relationship
with jeffrey
epstein you know those conspiracy
theorists say a small group of really
powerful people control the world and
have an interest in
little kids just a conspiracy theory but
we will tell you what we do know
that's just a head edgy stuff right so
just straight up pandering to cue and on
there
maybe this helps his ratings maybe he
has a big q anon
uh contingent in his audience i don't
really know then
sean hannity brings in donald trump jr
for a segment on the steele dossier
from uh was it 2016 2017
we're almost halfway through 2021
and hannity brings on the son of a
former president
to talk about a five-year-old document a
fox host
laura ingraham going with a narrative
about the democratic party
being in chaos and falling apart and
being in disarray
she had one headline called things are
clearly falling apart for democrats
and then another which included
right-wing bomb thrower
dinesh de souza as a guest
which was called quote gop views
gain traction as dems
in disarray and of course this is all
completely fake it's all completely made
up
if the current administration is notable
for anything it's that
we are four months in and there are just
no scandals and things are calm and
uncontroversial now we can all say well
joe biden didn't handle stopping
the deportations the way that he
promised and i would be right there with
you
and joe biden hasn't done enough here or
he hasn't done enough there or i don't
like
the deadline he set for when to get
troops out of afghanistan he said it at
september 11th he should have done it by
may 1st like donald trump
these are all fair criticisms and things
that we can all talk about but
there's really no disarray there's
really no scandal there's really no
chaos we're four months in
uh joe biden has gotten some major
things done most americans are more or
less happy with it and americans are
very happy with the coveted stimulus
bill that was done
americans are very happy with joe
biden's handling of the pandemic and
americans are very happy with joe
biden's handling of the vaccine rollout
lastly from laura ingram another
blockbuster powerful story called quote
the left doesn't actually have
an agenda and this one is particularly
funny
because joe biden passed covet stimulus
rolled out vaccines has a jobs bill
proposal
has an infrastructure bill proposal has
made some tweaks to gun safety doesn't
mean you have to like them or think
they're enough but he made some tweaks
to gun safety
and yet it is republicans who for four
years
and especially now openly so mitch
mcconnell said it
they are not about anything other than
stop
democrats from doing anything under
barack obama the republican agenda was
stop obama from doing anything under
trump the agenda was
undo anything we can that barack obama
did and under joe biden the agenda is
not really an agenda it's prevent joe
biden from doing anything
it's a good critique not having an
agenda not being for anything if it were
true
it happens to be true of the republican
party and
i don't know if they can do this for the
next four years like at some point
will they have to come up with something
more substantive to slam joe biden about
at some point i mean most presidents
have some scandals
obama was sort of out of the ordinary in
the sense that he didn't have any major
scandal
will they come up with something
substantive or will they will something
happen that is actually
a fair critique of joe biden that would
fall under the umbrella of scandal or
disarray
let me know what you think but they seem
committed
to trying to stop joe biden from doing
anything and from claiming that joe
biden is getting nothing done and is
embroiled in scandal when that's
actually not the case that's going on
let me know what you think can they do
this for four years without anything
substantive